-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We are back here with Lorde.
To be honest, how hungover
were you the next day?
-[ Exhales sharply, laughs ]
I almost can't
even talk about it.
I can't look at an alcoholic
drink ever again.
It was insane.
-I was -- We filmed this
last Monday, and then on Tuesday
you were on
"The Late Show
with Stephen Colbert,"
and I watched that very nervou
that I had somehow taken you out
so late that
you would not perform well
but you were wonderful
on that show.
-Thank you.
You did kind of destroy me
and I had to get a very
pop-star thing, an IV drip
-You didn't.
-Someone came to my hotel
and administered fluids
to my corpse.
-You kids and the things you do.
-The tick.
You know? [ Indistinct ]
The IV tick.